Let's do it.
Alright
I'll take that as a yes
What?
The ring
The world remains in mourning after the death of Superman
Violence, acts of war, and terrorism are all on the rise
I had a dream
It was the end of the world
Invasion
I think it's something more
Something darker
We're asking people we don't know to risk their lives
A strong man is the strongest alone, you ever heard that?
That's not a saying, that's the opposite of what the saying is
Divided, we are not enough
The world needs Superman
I've made him a promise
This is why I brought you together
The ride ain't over yet
Yeah!
Oh, awesome!
There's a bat signal...that's your...oh, shhh, sorry
That's your signal that means we have to go now
Yeah, that's...that's what that means.
It's so cool